back in this country the Biden
Administration has decided to crack down
on hidden extra fees for air Travelers I
don't think anyone likes those the
Department of Transportation plans to
require Airlines and travel websites to
reveal those charges up front instead of
adding them on the back end when you
make a reservation Chris Van Cleave is
at Washington's Reagan National Airport
Chris good morning so what's the reason
for doing this
well good morning you're absolutely
right Nate hidden and surprise fees are
a huge pet peeve of Flyers under this
proposed regulation both Airlines and
those third-party travel booking sites
would have to display not only the fare
but a whole bunch of additional
potential charges that could raise the
price we're talking about things like
cancellation fees baggage fees change
fees any additional costs for a family
to sit together it's an effort to give
consumers a clearer sense of the total
cost to travel from the beginning sort
of the all-in price right up front worth
noting many airlines have eliminated
cancellation and change fees now in a
statement Airlines responded to this
proposed regulation saying they already
offer transparency to Consumers from
first search to touchdown U.S airlines
are committed to providing the highest
quality of service which includes
Clarity regarding prices fees and ticket
terms President Biden also yesterday
directed his cabinet to identify hidden
or surprise fees in a host of Industries
and eliminate them things like late fees
overdraft fees early termination fees he
also called out the energy sector in
particular for not bringing down gas
prices faster Gail all right Chris thank
you it's